[Music]
to tap into the dopaminergic system you
said you needed a valued goal is there
any way to tap into the opioid system I
want to be more connected to people but
part of me can't get myself to care okay
well one of the things that that so
maybe you're a little bit on the
disagreeable side that's a possibility
there's some interesting clinical
evidence that suggests that one of the
things that disagreeable people can do
in order to facilitate their
interactions with other people is to do
people favors and so what you might say
is that you could start by acting like
you care and then maybe you could learn
how to care through doing that so maybe
you could say well I'm gonna do
something nice for someone once every
two days for a month and and think about
it a little bit and see what see if that
changes you because you know sometimes
you think yourself into change and
sometimes you act yourself into changing
your thoughts and so that's what I would
start by doing and you know you could
also be more connected to people
regardless of whether you care you know
let's say that it would take you six
months of practice or even a year of
practice before you care but that's not
so long especially if you're young so
that's what I would say about that